so women are watch I'm happier if you
look at national polls and they were
saying in the late 1950s and early 1960s
and I think that's partly because
freedom and happiness those are not the
same thing they're not even close
and you know I see young women all the
time struggling to figure out what to do
with their life they have no idea how to
have a job class career and a family so
and there's no answer to that it's a
really difficult problem you know and
there's all sorts of ideas like I did a
lot of consulting firm offers for a long
time about a decade in it I have a lot
of quiet through really high-functioning
female lawyer to younger ones trying to
figure out how to balance their career
with their desire to have life and you
know you hear all the time about women
being denied access to positions of
power and that that's the consequence of
prejudice and oppression it's like yeah
yeah everything is caused by the same
thing first right you've got one cause
of principle wonderful now you're a
philosopher you can figure out
everything with it like the law firms
cannot keep their women in their 30s
they cannot keep them too big law firms
they all leave why because the women hit
30 they're brilliant conscientious
intelligence they were deadly in high
school deadly in universities they
nailed Law School they went through
their articling they made harder by the
time limit surgeries like they're in a
rocket to the top position where they
find is a gift they're 80-hour workweeks
right because that's one of the things
you want to think about you know you
think that the people who run things are
sitting at home smoking big cigars is
like telling their minions what to do
it's like that is not stuff like the
1920s millionaire that's on the cover of
the Monopoly game that's Joey is post
illogical Adele I know lots of people
like that and they work all the time all
the time from the second they wake up to
the second they go to sleep and they
don't just casually work you know
because I know how me go to the library
for six hours you say while I study in
the library to six
what no you didn't you study for
happening that's Harvey and you look
through Facebook and you know I went
home what you said well I studied for
six hours or you're happy about it but
you know bloody well he did part because
you can you know I can only read for
about three and a half hours til I'm
done and I'm pretty good at it so these
people who are running things corrupt
people obviously but the vast majority
of them first ourselves minute and
second there are so bloody efficient
apart you cannot believe it and they
work 80 hours a week and most of them
happen to be met and why is that because
there are a small number of insane men
who will do nothing but work 80 hours a
week and no matter where do you put them
if you put them in the middle of the
forest it's an act all I would do is run
around chopping down trees so the end is
why aren't there more women in positions
of power it's why are there any men
insane enough ever to occupy those
positions you know because we also know
and the data on this is very clear
what's the relationship between money
and well-being once you have enough
money to keep the bill collectors from
your door so why do you have enough
money to save all miseries which is sort
of lower middle class something like
that in our society maybe a little
little lower than that extra money does
not help you
it does not improve your life so why
bother with it well that's what the
women in the law firms face it's like
most of them by the time they're in
their thirties are married almost all of
them are married to men who make as much
money or more than me because that's
what women go for cross-culturally four
to five years older equal or higher in
the socioeconomic status so they're
they're your husband's already made
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
a year so I say think well I don't need
much more money demanding is money to
keep track of the competition by the way
because all the male lawyers did I
talked to are usually real hard-ass guy
really low and agreeableness really high
conscious
like conservative type slow and openness
as well and they want to win and the
reason they care about your down bonus
at the end of the year isn't even so
much because of the money it's because
they got a much bigger bonus but the
other son-of-a-bitch city decides up and
they're happy about that so there's a
real like a real brass knuckles
competition that drives these sorts of
things but we get things backwards so
often it in psychology and sociology so
it's not why there aren't more women in
positions of power it's Widing any men
want those positions you just have no
idea the amount of responsibility that
comes along with that you just imagine
for a minute or two run a billion-dollar
corporation
you can't even bloody well balance your
checkbook and there's dust bunnies
underneath your bed how in the world
would you ever run a billion-dollar
corporation so it's been hard
complicated and you have enemies and
they're trying to take you out all the
time if you look at Apple and Samsung
and they're just torturing each other in
the courts non-stop you know yo if
you're if you're running a big
corporation you'll be you'll be handling
two or three hundred loss instead of
time and that's just that's just nothing
compared to the complexity of what you
actually have to do stay on top of the
technology constantly interact with your
large customers travel all the time
because if you have to maintain the
relationships you have to regulate the
politics inside the business you have
believe me it's no picnic and you think
what we get a lot of money it's like
what makes you think that such a good
thing you know like if you're half crazy
and you have a lot of money you're going
to be crazy a lot faster because it
frees you from all sorts of constraints
you know we know the data on lottery
winners they're no happier you're later
and some of them are done especially if
they had like a bit of a cocaine problem
to begin you know being broke doc you
from dying
you're a cocaine app you get enough
money in the way you go and you think to
yourself you know you've got all sorts
of bad habits and weirdnesses if
somebody dumped an infinite amount of
money on you what makes you think you
would unravel completely it's highly
probable so anyways so back to these
women
the
what they do when they're dirty as they
look around them today clean hit
partners so they get the technical
different profession they think what the
hell am I doing this for why would
anyone in the right mind want to be
woken up at 3:00 in the morning Sunday
by their irate Japanese client who
wanted them to work for the next five
hours non-stop
to fix this damn problem which is going
to cost them 100 million dollars right
now or we'll find someone else to pay
$750 an hour to to fix it right now and
you think well that's you know a
masculine for them value that because
that's one of the criticisms if the law
firms just adopted a more feminine
structure of values like what kind of
is that and the reason the
reason that you get up at 3:00 in the
morning on Sunday to talk to your
Japanese quietly is freaking out about
their contractors because you know jump
the hell up and do it right now there's
some starving associate who's
unbelievably ambitious in New York will
pick up the pieces in two tenths of a
second and they're smart aggressive and
they'll take you out so it has nothing
to do with masculine structures of
values although foolish ideas and you
know it's not just law with its habits
you know we know for example that female
doctors were far fewer our students so
the more female doctors you have the
more doctors you have to have and I'm
not complaining about women's priorities
I'm not saying the women are wrong not
at all just like the older I get the
more I understand that marriage and
family are a primary importance and the
more I see women in particular know they
get 35 or 40 and they're not married and
they don't have kids and they are not
happy because what the hell are you
going to do from the time you're 14 til
the top rating you got no family
you got no relationships what are you
going to do go run your company you know
well if your wasn't a sound that was
satisfying
so you bloody well better make sure
you're that one in the thousand and
you're probably not because those people
are rare